[Music]  i'm bret baer and i've been at fox news  for 23 years  when i think of 25 years i think about  how far we've come i was hired for the  atlanta bureau but there was no atlanta  bureau the atlanta bureau started in my  apartment with a fax machine and a cell  phone i had not heard of fox news  channel and neither had anybody that i  was calling for stories  as a reporter early on  it was i'm from fox news and they said  is that the simpsons network people said  this is a niche audience well it turns  out the niche was half the country  outside the pentagon right there for me  it was 9 11. i started doing live shots  with the burning pentagon behind me but  it changed me because i thought this is  big it's an honor it really is and to  think about all the stories that we've  covered all the things we've been  through as a network  it's really good to be here  [Music]  you